Roseanne Barr returned to Twitter
overnight hours after ABC cancelled her
hit show she issued a new apology for
her racist tweet about one of former
President Obama's closest confidants she
said I'm sorry for my tweet but also
wrote I'm tired of being attacked and
belittled more than other comedians who
have said worse ABC's you know move very
quickly yesterday to pull the plug on
bars number-one sitcom after she tweeted
that Valerie Jarrett who is black was
the daughter of the Muslim Brotherhood
and Planet of the Apes the president of
ABC entertainment called bars tweet a
pourraient repugnant and inconsistent
with our values
vladimir duthiers our streaming network
that CBS n is here with a fallout and
Valerie Jarrett's response good morning
good morning the fall has been Swift
following bars tweets she was also
dumped by her agents and three other
networks pulled reruns of Roseanne off
the air ABC now facing a gaping hole in
its fall schedule it stands to lose
millions in advertising dollars and
hundreds of jobs
roseann bars racist tweet was so
offensive
[Music]
it forced ABC to do something almost
unthinkable pulled the plug on its
number one show Valerie Jarrett the
senior Obama advisor bar compared to an
ape told the Town Hall last night she
received a personal apology from Disney
CEO Bob Iger he said that he had zero
tolerance for that sort of racist
bigoted comment and he wanted me to know
before he made it public that he was
cancelling his show last night after
retweeting several bizarre posts from
fans who came to her defense bar tweeted
guys I did something unforgivable so do
not defend me it was 2:00 in the morning
and I was ambien tweeting it was
Memorial Day too I went too far and do
not want it defended because late night
hosts weighed in you know who I blame
for this Donald Trump that's who even
ABC's own Jimmy Kimmel it's Rosanne
compared an african-american woman a
former adviser to President Obama to an
ape which did not sit well with ABC
management or anyone with a brain
released the Roseanne reboot on ABC drew
25 million viewers its first week
president Trump has credited
that shows high ratings to a perceived
focus on issues that resonate with his
supporters it was about us I think that
they knew what they were getting into
with Roseann entertainment tonight
co-host Kevin Frazier says by trying to
reach Trump supporters ABC took a huge
risk on Barr who outside of her support
for mr. Trump
traffic's in right wing conspiracy
theories and once compared Susan Rice
another African American Obama official
to an ape what does this do for networks
who are looking to catch the Trump train
this was the first attempt and it was
widely successful so I don't think it'll
be the last the talk co-hosts are
Gilbert who plays Rose Anne's daughter
Darlene is also an executive producer of
the show she tweeted I'm disappointed in
her actions to say the least
fellow comic Rosie O'Donnell called
Barse tweet racist and childish but
added I love Roseann quite a bit it'll
be interesting to see what they say on
the talk today because I'm sure Sara
Gilbert weren't address it but I think
people are really stunned and praising
Bob Iger and team for moving so quickly
I'm told that there was no debate no
discussion no resistance they just said
bull stop it's over yeah there will be
some time it is it is stunning there
will be some people who'll be upset
because they love the show and they love
the representation of their values they
feel fine
this was a swift and you don't want your
values to be represented by somebody who
talks like that
that's who says racist things right
Thank You fun